whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are some
nanny wants to ban it presenting the
nanny of the month runners-up a
Republican Party leader in Asbury Park
New Jersey and want to be a bikini
banner who's urging the City Council to
enforce a long ignored law that forbids
swimsuits on the boardwalk
she says they cut down her garden with
no cause and code cops in Tulsa who
ripped out Denise Morrison's garden even
though she says she was complying with
city codes I came back set in my
driveway cry and I left a judge later
cited with Morrison who's now suing the
city not only is this my plants my
livelihood but this was also my food but
this time the nation's top manny comes
to us from Middleborough massachusetts
gives become a modern-day plague of
source i'm talking about the public use
of vulgar curse words that were once
considered taboo residents in the small
town voted overwhelmingly to slap potty
mouths with fines of 20 bucks it's 20
bucks enough we'll find out the idea was
cooked up by the police chief we have a
lot more important things to do but
these are things that quality of life
issues to these protesters which truly
offensive is the law itself saying that
we are going to use the force of
government to control your speech is way
more offensive than any particular word
check back next month for more examples
of busybodies minded your own business
thanks for let you
you